one of the few actual policy takeaways
from that gong show press conference
last week that Trump gave which was
indistinguishable from a Saturday Night
Live parody was that he was promising
and his attorney said this that there
will be no new foreign deals whatsoever
during Donald Trump's administration by
his businesses this is an effort to
avoid the obvious conflict of interest
that he will not be able to avoid and
also that any pending new deals that are
foreign will be stopped that was the
promise made by Donald Trump and via his
attorney at last week's gong show press
conference unfortunately and I know that
it's very very soon for this to already
be happening it's sort of weird a
multi-million dollar expansion of Donald
Trump Scottish Golf Resort is going to
be happening the aberdeenshire council
has approved a new 18-hole golf course
and more housing at Trump International
Golf Links Scotland this is going to add
a 450 room 5-star Hotel timeshare
conflicts and private housing estate
it's going to add as I mentioned another
golf course it's going to significantly
boost the value of the Trump
Organization now you might say well
David this isn't really a new deal this
was a pending deal but again Trump's
attorney sherry Dillon announced last
week that in order to avoid potential
conflicts of interest all pending deals
will be terminated this was supported
after the press conference by a written
statement from dylan's law firm Morgan
Lewis which said again this agreement
prohibits without exception new foreign
deals during the duration of Donald
Trump presidency obviously the Trump
transition team was questioned last week
you say new foreign deals days later
you've got a new golf course in hotel in
Scotland they said that this is an
expansion this is not a new deal and it
was never a pending deal quote
implementing future phasing of existing
properties does not constitute a new
transaction so we will proceed who
believes this even if adhere to this is
sort of the problem with this
arrangement
that Trump is organized which is it's
all semantics right no new deals no
pending deals but this is fine because
it's just a phase of an old deal so i
guess nobody has to worry i don't know
if there's a silver lining it's that a
lot of these plans may not even come
into fruition scotland already hates
Donald Trump for the most part yeah I
guess and the initial plan he promised a
1.25 billion dollar investment turns out
it was some 50 million dollars he
promised 6,000 jobs maybe it was a
couple hundred so you can see why there
was a petition to even ban him from the
UK there's a documentary about the
entire Scottish golf course thing that
people check out bottom line on this is
that even if Trump adheres to the
agreement as he outlined it last
Wednesday it's still nonsense the office
of government ethics said that even as
presented Rachel even if Trump does
everything he said he would do that it
still is ethically and morally dubious
what he's doing here I don't believe
that there's any way that Trump would
avoid conflicts of interest I mean it
just it doesn't stand to reason that
it's even possible he's not going to
divest his kids are going to own these
businesses the entire thing was a smoke
and mirrors show it definitely was but I
don't understand how there's nothing
that's put in place to stop him from his
failure to meet an ethics standard that
every other president has upheld up
until this point this is what people
don't get people say David the
emoluments Clause of the Constitution
Trump can't do it because he's in
violation of the Constitution that
provides a framework under which you
could challenge what Trump is doing if
someone wants to actually challenge it
legally or the Office of Congressional
Ethics or whatever it doesn't
automatically do anything and we've
talked about that Pat someone needs to
go forward it doesn't do anything just
to say well this exists in the
Constitution okay but so now what and
also the emoluments Clause only deals
with accepting gifts from foreign
dignitary at the trip so I mean the
domestic front is still fair game there
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one remember we're
raising money to expand the David Pakman
show big league as well as expand
program
just activism go to david pakman.com
slash donate donations of any size are
much appreciated